la cuna del blues se vio muy afectada
por la pandemia ahora Memphis y sus
residentes tienen que lidiar con la
inflación Sandy ozmani dirige un
servicio de automóviles en la ciudad
Hola Jennifer soy Sandy de limusin
estaba llamando para confirmar tu
recogida hoy a las 3 en punto por
primera vez en 20 años Tuvo que aumentar
sus tarifas por hora en 15 dólares
debido al aumento de los precios de la
gasolina
no es solo la gasolina el seguro subió
el precio de los autos subió incluso las
bebidas que ponemos en los vehículos
para los clientes eso también subió la
servilletas todo subió
la inflación ha empeorado tanto las
cosas que ahora está considerando vender
su empresa por ahora sin embargo trata
de mantener su factura de gas lo más
baja posible
probaremos esta gasolinera shell al
menos debería obtener 5 centavos de
descuento ahora usamos diferentes
tarjetas de crédito que nos dan
descuentos por galón la regular es
bastante buena cuesta 3.79 dólares en el
sur la inflación alcanzó casi el 9%
interanual en septiembre casi medio
punto porcentual por encima de la tasa
nacional
con 30 dólares podría llenarlo Y ahora
estás buscando de 58 a 60 para llenarlo
culpa los demócratas por sus problemas
cada vez que hemos tenido un presidente
republicano parece que al país le está
yendo muy bien a pesar de todos sus
problemas Trump dirigió el país como un
negocio y funcionó para nosotros la
inflación no solo es dura para las
pequeñas empresas también está causando
estragos entre los agricultores Marvin
rody cultiva su hoja en las afueras de
Memphis en El delta del Mississippi pero
este año está operando con pérdidas
cultivo aproximadamente 121 hectáreas y
mis costos operativos pasaron de
aproximadamente de 200 dólares por
hectárea a 320 dólares por hectárea
solo quiero poder producir algo de
calidad y tratar de obtener una ganancia
para pagar nuestras facturas como
agricultores
la inflación ha empeorado desde la
guerra en Ucrania los precios del diesel
y los fertilizantes se han duplicado
para mantenerse a flote rodi ha llegado
a depender de sus compañeros granjeros
Tratamos de utilizar algunos equipos que
yo pueda tener y que él lo tiene
en lugar de que ambos compremos las
mismas cosas
ya sabes solo Tratamos de reducir costos
encuestas recientes han mostrado
consistentemente que la economía y la
inflación son por mucho la prioridad
número uno para los votantes
estadounidenses y entre esos votantes la
mayoría confía más en los republicanos
para arreglar dichos problemas